the movie starts as two modern looking
black men in their fancy underwear are
being sold off at an auction they are
chained by their necks and it appears as
if the place is a slave market following
this the movie goes back into a
flashback where it all started it
revolves around two estranged
half-brothers Regis and Joel gross this
year from the West Indies who lead
completely different lives Joel is a
mono-racial black man fresh out of
prison after serving time for stealing
an old woman's purse currently he lives
with his mother and his nine-year-old
daughter he is serially unemployed and
blames racism for all his woes
especially his joblessness however he
has never seriously tried to find work
on the other hand Regis is a biracial
man he is married to a white woman and
has a nine-year-old daughter with her he
lives in an affluent town and is well
integrated into the upper class Society
Regis is employed at the local town hall
and works as an assistant to the mayor
one day Regis receives a call from his
uncle informing him that his father is
dying and is the old man's final wish to
meet all his children however Regis pays
no regard to his deadbeat father as he
was not around when Regis was a child he
then proceeds to have dinner with his
family but his crazy wife threatens to
get laid with other men if he does not
pay his father one last visit she jumped
to that specific threat awfully quickly
left with no choice he reluctantly
agrees the next day Regis takes a flight
to his hometown where his father resides
at the airport he runs into Joel who has
also come to see their father the
brothers who have been out of contact
for more than a decade put their
differences aside and hire a taxi
together they catch up in the taxi on
the way to their father's home Regis
tells Joel everything about his
successful life while the latter lies to
cover up his failures out of
embarrassment upon reaching their
father's home they are introduced to
their aunt and several half-sisters
turns out that their dad ventured
throughout the world and had relations
with countless women this explains why
Joel and Regis have different skin
colors the old man's eyes light up when
he sees his only two sons before him
before dying he tells Regis and Joel
that they will inherit a great treasure
this excites the brothers and they
eagerly wait to hear about the treasure
however to their dismay all they receive
as inheritance is the document of
emancipation of their ancestors this
document was handed over to a few Slaves
by their owners for some extraordinary
work or act apparently Regis and Joel's
ancestors were granted freedom long
before slavery was legally abolished in
the West Indies however not concerned
about the symbolic value of this piece
of paper they scoff at The Inheritance
they then derisively tear the paper up
under the disapproving eye of their late
father sister as expected this enrages
the old woman so she decides to teach
the bratzel lesson she casts a voodoo
spell on them and sends them back to the
17th century where slavery is still
prevalent in the next scene when Regis
and Joel wake up they find themselves
stripped down to their designer
underwear in an open field as the two
wonder about what happened a couple of
terrified black people will run past
them just then two slave Hunters also
arrive and capture the gross to Seer
Brothers they are then taken to a slave
market and sold to monsieur Jordan a
landowner Jordan entrusts Joel to the
Farms where he will work under the care
of Henri a brutal and deeply racist
Foreman while Regis is sent to the
kitchens of the residence soon the
half-brothers Discover that they have
actually time traveled to 1780 when
slavery was still a thing the next day
the slaves are forced to listen to a
priest who reads them a fake Bible about
how black people should obey the whites
but since the gross to see your brothers
are the only ones besides the whites who
can read they refuse to agree with the
contents Regis even surprises the priest
by reading him a line from the book
later in the day Joel shows up late to
the field and gets hit by Henri fed up
with Henry's torture and behavior Joel
makes a run for it to escape the farm
but ends up hitting his head on a pole
and knocking himself out due to his
actions he is scourged in front of
everyone that night Regis is called to
Jordan's office where his ability to
read is acknowledged Jordan Praises him
for being a smart slave and gives him
the privilege to control the other
slaves with Henri in the meantime Joel
is getting his wounds treated by a
female slave Rosalie it has been only
five minutes since they've met but Joel
has already started liking her at an
opportune moment he leans in for a kiss
only to get turned down Rosalie then
reveals that she is in love with a
fellow slave named Isador much to Joel's
disappointment the next day Regis
carries out his new Duty and starts
ordering and commanding other slaves to
do their work Joel is shocked to see his
brother acting like the whites and
criticizes him for being selfish however
Regis could care less and he continues
to be loyal to his new Masters and
reports his work throughout the day to
monsieur Jordan eventually everyone in
the White household finds out about
regis's ability to read and starts
mocking him they also joke about whether
or not he can play the piano to
everyone's surprise Regis plays the
piano beautifully however this this
results in him getting whipped severely
by the whites finally Fed Up Regis wants
out and the next morning the two
brothers flee the plantation by secretly
hopping in the carriage of a Jewish man
named Isaac when they reach his place
Isaac approaches them and reveals that
he knew about their presence All Along
The Brothers begged him for Mercy but to
their surprise Isaac provides them with
great hospitality and care as Jews are
also a victim of discrimination soon
Monsieur Jordan's henchmen arrive at
Isaac's home in search of the two
brothers but before they could get
caught Regis and Joel bid Isaac farewell
and flee through the back door they make
their way to the Shoreline where they
take an abandoned boat and set out into
the ocean ironically they cross paths
with a ship that is used to transport
slaves to auctions and are caught and
imprisoned at last the gross to seeer
Brothers end up in the same slave market
where they are bought by Jordan's
henchmen fortunately on the way back to
the plantation the brothers are saved by
an African tribe who call themselves The
Maroons here it is revealed that the
people of the tribe were all slaves once
before they fled from their owners that
you are welcomed into the tribe and they
began to chant with the tribe leader
however Regis who himself is married to
a white girl refuses to chant when the
Maroons talk about killing the whites
this enrages the tribe and they quickly
turn on the brothers but fortunately
Regis and Joel managed to outrun the
tribe and reach safety the next day the
two find themselves in an unknown place
where they see their aunt who cast a
spell on them the brothers soon realized
that it was she who is responsible for
sending them back in time they plead
with her to remove the spell and mention
that they will do anything for it
initially the old woman refuses but when
the brothers keep pleading she gives
them a hint she tells them that the only
way for them to get back to the present
is to reach the plantation again and
reunite their ancestors Isador and
Rosalie she also tells them to rectify
the error without elaborating any
further she's probably referring to Joel
trying to make out with his
great-great-grandmother before
disappearing the woman leaves behind her
special pipe and instructs the brothers
to smoke it when they have successfully
completed their mission as the two are
brainstorming ways to tackle the
situation Joel suddenly remembers seeing
what seemed like Isidore having oral
intercourse with another man he also
recorded a video of the incident on his
phone and shows it to Regis questionable
move Joel the two brothers then become
convinced that Isador is homosexual and
they mistakenly believe that this is the
error that they are supposed to fix in
the next scene Joel and Regis returned
back to the plantation they try to
negotiate with Monsieur Jordan on their
punishment but it doesn't work out for
them instead they get branded with a
Sigil of the plantation they then return
to their huts and begin to plan their
course of action meanwhile inside the
Mansion the whites are celebrating the
wedding party of Monsieur Jordan's
daughter taking this as the perfect
distraction the brothers organize a
party of their own for the slaves they
secretly steal a barrel of rum from The
Distillery to intoxicate and to activate
the romance between Isador and Rosalie
how however their plan hits a roadblock
when Regis spots Joel making out with
Rosalie due to his infatuation with her
afterwards the two brothers improvise
and physically help the couple have
intercourse as they're asleep what once
this is done they're convinced that
their mission there is accomplished
believing that they can go home whenever
they like the brothers decide to take
revenge on the whites they then make
their way into the Mansion armed where
they humiliate everyone Joel kisses the
daughter of Monsieur Jordan whereas
Regis starts damaging furniture and even
slaps a white man all of a sudden Henri
barges into the room with a gun and
threatens the brothers Still Regis and
Joel show no sign of fear and proceed to
use the pipe unfortunately when they
smoke it nothing happens it appears as
if the magical pipe given by the old
lady was replaced with an ordinary one
as a result of their deeds they are
locked in a cage and are condemned to
execution the next day that night the
brothers get emotional and start
contemplating their life choices Regis
talks about his failing marriage while
Joe confesses that he is broke and
jobless after a few hours as the
brothers are still sympathizing with
each other Henry arrives and takes them
out to the field where they're supposed
to be hanged however right before the
execution Monsieur Jordan's son Victor
runs off into the forest as he cannot
bear watching the site Rosalie chases
after him and soon finds out that he has
fallen into the nearby River all members
of the family panic and run to the scene
however Isidore takes advantage of the
Uproar and saves the brothers knocking
out Henry in the process he then orders
them to run for their lives to which
they oblige as the brothers flee they
come across Victor who is being swept by
the stream without a second thought the
two jump into the dangerous river but to
regis's surprise Joel cannot swim this
makes his task even more difficult but
somehow he manages to save both his
brother and Victor grateful to the
brothers for saving his son's life
Monsieur Jordan sets them free the half
brothers are also awarded with the very
same document of emancipation that they
were provided with by their late father
how however instead of accepting the
freedom and the award they request
Monsieur Jordan to free Isador and
Rosalie and present them with the
document the Monsieur finds the request
very strange but nonetheless he obliges
in this way the brothers have managed to
free Isidore and Rosalie but they still
don't know where to find the magical
pipe which will help them return back to
the Modern Age with days passing by they
slowly begin to accept that they may
never return to their time one day
Isidore and Rosalie wish the brothers
farewell and to leave the plantation
with the papers as the two watched them
leave from afar Henri approaches them
and orders them to get back to work he
then takes out his pipe and starts
smoking when he tries to humiliate the
brothers by blowing smoke in their faces
they suddenly disappear much to the
astonishment of honoree this indicates
that Henri was the one who stole the
pipe from them in the next scene the
brothers return back to the present
where they see their aunt beside them
when they see her holding the original
document in her hand Regis and Joel
become relieved several months pass by
Joel finds a regular job on a
construction site where he still
complains about his minimum wage and
that it has to do with him being black
meanwhile Regis returns to his work at
the Town Hall one day as he is about to
leave his office he greets the mayor who
passes a racist joke Regis being no
longer the person he once was decides to
stand up to the mayor before storming
off the scene then cuts to Regis and his
wife along with Joel and his mother
chatting in regis's living room the two
agree that the adventure they had
brought them closer as a family but an
argument between their respective
daughters leads to the tearing of the
document of emancipation the movie ends
as the two brothers run towards their
daughters in panic subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching